what do you think happened to
neanderthals what did we
cheeky humans do to the neanderthals
homo sapiens do you think we murdered
them was it
how do we murder them how do we
out-compete them
um
do we i made them i don't know i mean i
i think there's unequivocal evidence
that we mated with them yeah we always
try to meet with everything yes pretty
much
there's some interesting the first
sequences that came along were in
mitochondrial dna
um and that was back to about 2002 or
thereabouts
what was found was that neanderthal
mitochondrial dna was very different to
human mitochondria that's so interesting
you could do a clock on it and it said
the divergent state was about 600 000
years ago or something like that so not
so long ago
um and then the first full genomes were
secrets maybe 10 years after that um and
and they showed plenty of signs of
mating between so so the mitochondrial
dna effectively says no mating
and the the nuclear
genes say yeah lots of mating um but we
don't know is that possible so can you
explain the difference between
mitochondrial cell yes and new uh
nucleus i've talked before about the
mitochondria which are the power packs
in cells these are the paired down
control units is that is their dna
so
it's passed on by the mother only
and
in the egg cell we might have half a
million copies of mitochondrial dna
there's only 37 genes left
and and they do a
it's basically the control unit of
energy production that's what is that's
what it's doing it's a basic old-school
machine that does and it's got genes
that were considered to be effectively
trivial because they did they did a a
very narrowly defined job but they're
not trivial in the sense that that
narrowly defined job is about
everything is being alive yeah um so
so they're much easier to sequence
you've got many more copies of these
things and you can sequence them very
quickly
um but the problem is because they go
down only the maternal line from mother
to daughter your mitochondrial dna and
mine is going nowhere doesn't matter any
kids we have they get their mother's
mitochondrial dna
um except in very very rare and strange
circumstances
um
and so it tells a different story and
it's not a story which is easy to
reconcile always
um and and what it seems to suggest to
my mind at least is that there was
one-way
uh traffic of genes probably going from
humans into neanderthals rather than the
other way around
why did the younger thills disappear i i
don't know i mean i i suspect that they
were
i suspect they were probably less
violent
less clever
uh less populous
less
willing to fight i i don't know i mean i
i think it drove them to extinction at
the margins of europe
and it's interesting how much if we ran
earth over and over again
how many of these branches of
intelligent beings
that have
figured out some kind of
um how to leverage collective
intelligence
which ones of them emerge which ones of
them succeed is it the more violent ones
is it um
uh the more isolated one you know like
what dynamics results in more
productivity and we i suppose we'll
never know it's
the more complex the organism the harder
it is to run the experiment in the lab
yes
and in some respects maybe it's best if
we don't know yeah the truth might be
very painful
you